le pétrole va coûter de plus en plus
cher je suis parce qu'on va reparler de
plus en plus aussi de l'énergie
nucléaire jean pierre chevènement le
ministre de la recherche à l'ouvré ce
matin justement en plein mois d'où une
conférence sur les techniques du
nucléaire dans le monde et il en a
profité d'ailleurs pendant une pause
d'une heure à peu près pour rencontrer
l'envoyé spécial du président ronald
reagan monsieur ben but d'une réunion
technique et non politique une réunion
technologique même on a beaucoup parlé
fiabilité et sécurité
monsieur jean pierre chevènement mais
s'en est expliqué ou contre la vérité
est de savoir dans quelles proportions
il faut que l'énergie nucléaire entre de
la composition du bilan énergétique et
c'est une réponse évolutive c'était
peut-être sérieux dans ce domaine il
faut savoir ce que nous pouvons faire et
ce que nous ne pouvons pas ne pas faire
et je crois que nous ne pouvons pas nous
passer du nucléaire on peut développer
d'autres formes d'énergie condition de
savoir que cela prend toujours du temps
pour qu'une forme d'énergie nouvelles
arrivent à maturité ce sont des
problèmes techniques qu'ils appliquent
que on raisonne sérieusement il ya
évidemment des risques liés à la
radioactivité qui re nucléaire mais ces
risques peuvent être assumés je crois
que c'était l'intérêt de cette
conférence qui est d'une violence de
spécialiste de mécanique de en matière
de technologie directeur de
d'assurer une très bonne fiabilité des
matériels fait en sorte qu'il y ait une
réelle sécurité je crois que l'industrie
nucléaire a montré jusqu'à présent que
l'avait su faire progresser de père à la
fois son propre développement est le
souci de la sécurité